I cook for warthogs EMU lions tigers
hyenas spoonbill Sunbear flamingos and
giraffe they can be very picky
every morning I am preparing around 350
pounds of food my name is Stacy Kyle's
and I prepare the food for the animals
at the Oakland Zoo I'm also known as
physician my day starts off very early
before the Sun even comes up I've got to
get the food for the animals or we have
nothing to prepare the calm before the
storm of getting into the market I need
to get about a ton of food today
literally the produce market is kind of
hectic you've got a lot of torquas
running back and forth you've got trucks
everywhere there's a lot to choose from
I have to stay organized or this can get
very overwhelming I've got a huge market
that I've got to go through I've got to
pick out the right produce so I have a
limited amount of time at the market
because I have to get back here to
prepare the diets I open the door to the
kitchen and then I know my day has truly
begun
[Music]
Sun bears 48 grams Apple Kawada Monday
three hard-boiled eggs lioness ten bones
and miles just breaks off seven servings
only 60 grams of cricket one driver the
vitamin 44 grandma the zoo itself as a
whole prepares about a thousand diets a
day so that's anywhere from the
elephant's down to the leaf-cutter ants
and all the little reptiles and the
little frogs it's important that we get
the diets right because the animals
can't send the food back they can't tell
us oh I don't like this we don't take
days off everything still has to happen
the food gets prepared exactly the same
way every single day I tried telling
those Christmas once they didn't pay
attention
[Music]
I'm a city boy I'm from New York never
seeing in a cow or anything like that
hanging out with EMU it's pretty cool I
don't probably won't have an opportunity
like that and rest of my life
[Music]
we are at the Monroe County Sheriff's
Office animal farms on the grounds of
the detention center we have the
capacity to have 700 inmates in all
three of our jail facilities this is the
main jail and we're the only facility of
this kind in the country that has a
exotic theory at a jail it started out
with just farm animals and now I have
exotic animals of all varieties
kinkajous are from the rainforests of
Central and South America that's the
bird we call the I love you bird and he
is such a camera hog we only take in
animals that have been abandoned abused
confiscated or donated hi Tucker we
don't purchase any of the animals and
they're here for their life this is a
forever home for them I'm in here just
for a year you know and these guys are
doing a life sentence I'm oh alright
Kramer gonna wake you up pretty girl
today I have four inmates every day they
come down here to feed water and clean
and then to spend time with the animals
what's going on buddy you're gonna get
out pretty soon mandatory rec the farm
is one of the jobs in this facility that
you could actually be outside all day at
number two
to interact with a bunch of rare cool
animals like Kramer here he's got the
little curl on the top of his head
that's why we call him Kramer this is he
or he he was uh he was saved from a
slaughterhouse and he's a lot better off
do you think working with the animals
helps the inmates with their
rehabilitation I've seen a lot of very
positive changes I've seen people that
come down here and are completely scared
of animals and by the end of their time
here then e of them bring their families
back to actually show them what they
were doing when they were incarcerated
I'm so happy to be out here when I first
came he was like not even this big tiny
and now look at you
[Music]
[Applause]
Blakely has the most difficult job as
Cincinnati Zoo he has to play with
babies all the time he's never shown any
aggression or snapped if he gets upset
kind of like any mom would he just
leaves the room my name is dawn Strasser
and we're at the Cincinnati Zoo and
Botanical Gardens
Lake Lee is a five year old Australian
Shepherd we got him from a rescue and I
use him in a nursery as a nanny or a
companion dog this is about you and
you're taking a nap
blakeley's here for the main purpose of
teaching the babies the correct animal
cues as they grow up so when they are
introduced back to their own kind they
know what appropriate behavior is he
teaches them how to play and how to
interact I can tell them no don't bite
me but I'm not an animal and I don't
give the same cues that he can so we
make a great team Blakely has worked
with cheetahs ocelots a talk in battered
foxes a warthog Wallabies to name a few
he's working with baby cheetahs right
now it's been a long seven weeks for him
with these little cheetah cubs and he's
I think tired because he's on alert for
24 hours a day if they start making too
much noise he'll come and get us like
something's not right
something's not right he's kind of like
a second set of eyes for us too a lot of
times they still recognize each other
like Dale the talk and he raised when
they see each other he'll they'll still
run up up front
grunt at him and he'll kind of jump up
on the wall and it's kind of like hey
how you doing thank you yeah well I like
to think I have an office but I'm pretty
sure it's his
[Music]
milk
it's the elixir all mammals feed to
their young deep inside the National Zoo
in Washington DC a team of scientists
are devoted to unlocking the wonders of
the white gold to help animals like baby
Fiona
but more on that later welcome to the
world's largest collection of exotic
animal milk ok let's get to it
meet dr. Michael power can I call you
Mike sure okay Mike what do you do here
I'm the curator of the exotic animal
milk repository at the Smithsonian's
National Zoo
it's the largest by a species count a
number of samples of milk in the entire
world we have samples that have been
collected from all over the world that
we keep in frozen storage animals like
armadillos bats giraffe giant anteater
Asian elephant African lion
cheetahs Tigers sea lions and zebra I
hate to ask but how do you get the milk
well I'll let the Tang show you the Tang
is a critically endangered Bornean
orangutan so this is the classic
collaboration between a scientist and
the animal care staff their incredible
work and effort it be able to training
the animals to be able to accept this
procedure to where they voluntarily
donate samples so now that we know the
how we have to ask why the exotic mammal
milk repository serves two critical
purposes one is basic science that's
simply trying to understand in a sense
the origin of milk and the other is a
very practical pragmatic purpose in the
fact that we have to occasionally
handler animals and therefore we have to
come up with a milk replacer formula
okay so when a baby can't be fed by
their mother you guys help come up with
a formula that's as close to the
mother's milk as possible have you heard
about baby Fiona at the Cincinnati Zoo
he's a baby hippo who's stolen the
hearts of people all over the country
baby fiona was born six weeks premature
she's a Nile hippo and no other
hippo had been hand raised in North
America and so we needed to put together
a milk formula to be able to feed her to
have her grow so we worked together with
the exotic animal milk repository at the
National Zoo to come up with a formula
to feed baby feeling
so how's Fiona doing now milk is almost
removed from her diet we are very happy
that baby Shona is happy and healthy and
growing very well awesome back to Mike
so what's next
the milk repository has samples from
over a hundred and eighty species of
mammals and that sounds pretty
impressive until you realize that
there's anywhere from five to six
thousand species of mammals so we have
only sampled maybe three percent of the
mammals still only a tiny tip of the
iceburg compared to what we could be
learning in the middle of a political
upheaval one Ukrainian zoo keeper set
out to make a difference in his own way
on the private estate of an Austin
president
[Music]
Sergei used to be a zoologist at the
Kiev Zoo Miami asaji who worried
yeah Picasso was at Warren Michigan one
night in 2014 he was watching the news
and learned that amidst the chaos
ukrainian President Viktor Yanukovych
had fled his compound in measure hero
leaving his private zoo behind we're
we're appreciative as we put the
witnesses shooted story moment shooter
Jewish was when he arrived Sergei was
stunned by the huge opulent estate and
saw the animals needed desperate care
there was a whole Deborah was very he
who must memory the more prosthetics
were in tot norrisville his room you
should Trevor Bratton a saber it Polly
diminished what he thought might be just
a few days has turned into four years
push no no samarenko
all doing away with you fetch walk
Strauss you all we knew when a horse
near on of jacquard woven apply
mysteriously no reservoir new territory
materia technically laboratory yes a -
goodness Toni Valliere what no more
absolutely no food no service near
Castle the key thought we heard away
Sammy today Sergei and a handful of
volunteers take care of thousands of
animals on the estate I am a Muslim with
the world over to tour in town DePalma
haughty in what is an email
Ximena - Paulo is Roberta starina mascot
Lamonica team sure to eliminate them
with started a movie - a rock rocky
dicey sweet he Seneca Patriots of Sydney
the zoo is slowly growing and Sergei has
big hopes for the future
Hazara school Yanukovych was tiny
sorry oak acute observer of geology here
Deep Ecology West Nadia a young boy the
British or miss a national park pakka
SOT I've seen leaking genome - raggy
Avada lapses Epidaurus group - al akir
oh she we Canadian Miss Rosa merely to
tration it is perfectly good evening
[Music]